so why did I get a facelift as a 25 year old man
before you come ahead judging me
this is not a typical facelift
this is a Korean facelift
because I was mad unhappy with what I was seeing in the mirror
so when I went in for a consultation
they started telling me I needed Botox laser
and they were gonna charge me like £3,000
like bro
I'm from a council estate in Birmingham
you think I can afford that
anyway I kept seeing all of these women
not like influences
like women in their 30s 40s 50s
60s all using this same Korean system
and then I realized my mom's been using this this entire time
and if you think I got a facelift
you are stupid this is my mom
no Botox no filler
literally no makeup tell me if I'm wrong
but she looks about 10 years younger
and I never used to look like this either man
until I started stealing her skincare
so let me explain to you what she uses
first off you're gonna start with a pink speculum
and people are calling this micro needling in a bottle
because this has tiny little particles that penetrate the skin
which stimulates cell turnover and collagen production
this is a really deep exfoliant that you're supposed to use like 2
3 times a week next up
you're gonna use the picotonic serum
supporting with redness uneven tones
supporting with pigmentation
literally just put this on my hand
and in two seconds look at how clear that looks
next up people are calling this the Korean Botox stick
and it's because of the active ingredients inside here
so just Calcium and raboni
you just literally put this on like your small orange
your crow's feet
my mum uses this everyday and just carries it in her handbag
then you gonna go ahead and take these patches
with the exact same technology
and put them under your eye bags
honestly these two have probably made the biggest difference
and lastly a big tip
if your neck looks like this
this is the firm and cream ripe
and my mom uses this every single night
and when you actually put it on
your neck gonna wake up and it's gonna feel quite tight
that's completely normal
this is formulated with rabonic and Calcium gluconate
and hydrolyzed elastin listen yeah
I don't know what's going on with Korea
but their skincare is next level
but please don't be stupid and buy each of these separately
as that's gonna cost you a fortune
instead on TikTok Shop
you can get this entire Korean skincare bundle on a massive sale
just read the reviews and check how cheap this deal is and get it
because I'm not sure how long this is gonna last